all right what up guys welcome to the
just pearly things YouTube channel
um so today this week I'm in Miami and
guys I went to this Bitcoin conference
because my cousin he's so into Bitcoin
like this man lives breathes dies by
Bitcoin and I just kind of wanted to see
like what the big deal is hang out with
my cousin a bit
and I was just curious so I'm doing a
video called I got I got orange pills
and essentially to me going to this
conference doing nothing about Bitcoin
learning about Bitcoin and it's really
interesting to see like Twitter is such
a serious Place guys and I'm sorry I've
lost
I've lost my voice a bit so you have to
bear with me but one I've never been
recognized so much in my life
I've lost my voice because so many
people came up to me and were talking to
me I'm like uh
I was shocked because I really like live
my life not thinking I'm famous because
in real life like I'm not you know I'm
just I'm just your girl pearl but
I'll go to places like this and I'm like
Jesus
a lot of people know who I am
now
it's interesting a lot of people on
Twitter really don't understand my
sarcasm because I tweeted I'm like I'm
orange filled guys and I'm just you know
messing around on Twitter but the very
serious tweeters
the very serious tweeters are like oh my
God she's a grifter oh my God she's a
panderer oh my God I see her pandering
in real time and it's funny I think that
the people that call me a grifter are
the biggest grifters because they notice
like they see it in themselves and they
don't really understand people that have
a Natural Curiosity about the world like
if I see people that are so die hard in
a group I want to know like why they
feel so strongly about something but
these crazy
tweeters like this one dude
he he gets very upset and I also think
it's kind of like a lack of masculinity
today all these guys that just get so
mad at a girl looking at Bitcoin anyways
that's not that's not why I did this
coffee talk to them
I did this coffee talk because I saw
I saw this girl tweet about Farm Life
and this girl she was tweeting it's my
dream to live on a farm okay and I'm
like all right all right girl go good
for you but this girl like clearly lives
a very modern lifestyle right lives in
an apartment in a major city and I got
to thinking about my childhood okay and
in my childhood I grew up on 40 acres we
had four wheelers
um we did not farm the land but we had
you know a garden we had chickens and
ducks and I really wasn't into the whole
gardening thing I was a volleyball
player okay but I did have pet chickens
and dogs oh my gosh I was I loved my
chickens and ducks
for a time period but what I realized is
I was like none of these girls have done
an ounce of farm work in their life
ever and they're talking about how they
want to
they want to live on a farm and I'm
thinking guys okay we used to get
furniture from the Amish when I was a
kid and it's so interesting these women
that will talk about oh I need to not
work to be feminine soft life blah blah
blah when I'm like ladies
if you saw how these Amish women lived
who are very very feminine
they got up at the crack of dawn to like
milk the cows
they were scooping up poop like like
this Farm Life stuff guys hey this is
not the Glamorous lifestyle you think it
is I promise and this is the problem
with us women I don't even think we know
when we're lying to ourselves like I
really
and this is no hate right if you want to
do that no hate but I just have a hard
time believing
these women that have never done an
ounce of farm work in their life ever
even close to lived that lifestyle like
if you wanted you could move out of the
city Into The Burbs
um and you know
live in
a little townhouse or something and
really start the farm life like put a
garden in your backyard you know but
these women they don't even know what
they want they've seen some soft life
Farmer's Life thing on Instagram and now
they're like wow my life I see this
luxury of living with all this land I
see this luxury of like growing my own
food wow this looks so great and fun
ladies it's not what you think it and
it's actually great for people that like
it but my thing is know thyself
know thyself
and you really gotta because men can
sense the a lot of times before
we can
and
I'm just saying if you really wanted to
live on a farm and not just what you see
on Instagram about living on a farm
I think you'd probably be on a farm
now the next people I'm beefing today
what other I just I like to give you
guys updates on my Twitter
oh women would be happier if men woke up
and realize they're the prize it's so
sad
to see so many relationships completely
ran by women now what do I mean when I
say this
if a woman selects a man
historically the majority of men did not
reproduce so the majority of men
aren't going to get picked but if a
woman picks a man that means he's in the
top 20 30 40 whatever you want to
include let's just say 40 percent of
them
because she picked him
so she's not going to pick a guy that
she feels like is worse than her so if
you're in a relationship with a woman
you're the prize and it's really sad to
see in the long run what female-led
relationships do to men it's like you'll
see these guys so afraid of their wives
like they can't make a decision oh
without my wife's approval I can't do
that it's like they can't live the way
they want to live and the women aren't
happy either because this pansy's afraid
of them so
foreign Not all men are the prize all
right I I feel like I have to clarify
like I'm speaking to two-year-olds
sometimes on the internet because
yeah what are the
of course men are the prize that's what
they're saying and then it's like I say
these basic things and then people will
quote we meet and say I'm I'm a panderer
or a grifter I didn't even know what
that meant before I got in this space
and I swear the biggest grifters they're
all these like kind of dorky guys or
women that just kind of sit at their
computers all day they're like keyboard
Warriors they're keyboard Warriors
they're like
it's a very weird part of Twitter
but I'm thoroughly enjoying myself so
let me know what you guys think in the
comments do the women really want Farm
Life they might I'm not saying they
don't I just I would like to see if they
still think that if they lived on a farm
for a month
because I I think a lot of times the
women think it's one thing and it's not
the thing you think it is
but let me know in the comments like the
video on your way out subscribe to the
channel I'll talk to you next time